Trump supporters resistance to judging
Trump on his merits of which there are
none you know comes down in part to this
with let's loop back to that rebellion
against the elites now one of the things
that there has been tremendous scorn for
and fun made of Trump indeed indeed
Trump supporters and when you are angry
at the establishment and you see the
establishment not just disagreeing with
your candidate but mocking their
candidate there is an element this isn't
they're mocking me they're mocking me
all these people at the New York Times
going on and on about how this is
impossible this horrible person cannot
possibly be President they're saying
that I am so you know because I support
him you know they're looking down on me
it's all these fancy college-educated
people and I'm the one doing the hard
work you know I'm they're looking down
at me and so there was a almost every
time you went out to make fun of Trump
you increased his support because people
were feeling scorned you know and when
people feel that they are Outsiders you
cannot convince them by mocking them and
you can't convince them by mocking or
their position we had to either wait for
what seems I hope to have happened for
the guy's head to explode you know or we
had to take you know some sort of other
approach to this and say well you know
let's let's look at it from this angle
or you know maybe this is a good reason
to vote for the Libertarian Party or
maybe anyway the scorn does not one when
people feel scorned to heaped scorn upon
them in